good morning have been
the nights we talk about custom items
custom elements are a specification
html5 and abolished the yes that allows us to
create building elements from the tag
these custom behaviors
items can be used in
three our website and one
internet explanation and wanting can
also be distributed through gods
javascript file in this example
we will use an element that does not exist
within the normal html5 tag e
built in this way so there
imagine an element called g
tantino profile with a user id and an ep
and who is it
we expect we want to implement one
functionality for which once
specified username and a key
for this element we would like this
element displayed washed
correspondent legislators of
selected on the account of the account
google plus
so we must say do two kinds of
interventions the first is to make sure that
our page accepts this element
as an element like
html5 elements and the second part of
this project is to add
a particular behavior to this
element that is precisely to go
to use the folds of google plus e
recover the user's lava
selected a small note
still specifies very much in the process of
development for which to say find this
example you need to use the
version of chrome channels then the com
from 31 onwards and enable the
if you read it specifically what it is called
nebo the office plasma experiment
inside the flags they say canary one
once this is done we go to recover
a google plus
in this case we can use the
my so more blood paganotti and it
we populate within our del
our custom item and let's go to
create a personalized pichi for
this project using the epia
google console then we bind ourselves
on the p to the console
let's create a new project e
let's go to the 94 new project a
select from the beige board that comes to us
presented the e and google plus that
are present in the alcohol page is here that
I call swan and we activate precisely
the use of google plus of hype
this application
then we move to ip access and
let's go and copy the lape who is that
which we will need to log in
at the foot
at this point our element is
complete and as information but
obviously it does absolutely nothing
it's up to us to get it accepted first
item on the page e
then provide it with the interaction
required to display avatars
and at the time of loading the
flat two points the same enough
in fact the specifications quickly
provide a new document more
called document point register e
once invoked point documents
register with the first argument i
name of the html element we want
generate in this case ti profile
we are confident that the element in
question will be assimilated and managed by
ours from our common normal browser
htm element
in addition as a second parameter like
second attribute we can specify
a prototype then we can associate
to the element a javascript object e
we can go and associate this
object some properties that cate gift
the element in this case our top
prototype is called proto and we have to
first initialize this
object in this way so let's go
build a product variable in that
actually it is simply a new one
constructed object starting from the element
basic html and let's go to the ad
one of the callbacks that these pays and puts
available and called the created of
callback and therefore that with the beautiful climate is
called whenever one of the
custom elements of our interest
enter the inside of this page
in case we can quickly check the
correct behavior of this first
instruction set uses non-LED
this means that in the moment in
which we are going to launch this
application the element ends
within the page and then comes
launched the critic the back for
the newly inserted element which
should print the led
ok how we can see the answer is
absolutely the expected one and the letter e
browser notifies us that the call back
was correctly called this
point the first thing we need to do if
we just want to recover the avatar
user whose specified profile
in the user id tribute and we must be able to
we will have to build an http xml call
15 will need a set of parameters a
certain number of parameters we can
go and recover and these are
so let's go to which first of all
inside the variable from a
malaka ttp object that quest that one
which he uses to actually do the
call let's retrieve the two
attributes used render
of the custom element then user id e
who are the ones who serve for
self
detailing the call we will go to
do and save the purpose of the function
inside the self this variable
it will then help us to maintain
the ability to manipulate the element
even when we are in functions
different
ok once this is done we will not stay
that make the call then
make the call to the pe of
google in this case the service of us
interested is at the https address
www.google.com the former plus v1 people lo
user id we have chosen is the key
the petite peaks that we have created little
does and send this call and put us
listening to the fault of the call back is
tied to the yacht themes to associate one
function to the property a load this
function what it does receives the jason is
generated by google plus with all
user information and extracts
we can see at the dam 14 and stay in
an html element including a link e
an image two properties of this jesus
also they are 2 ml and the image once
did this
we notice how this string actually is
keane alta also contains elements
html is not entered directly
the element but is inserted in one
shadow dom
this because we have seen in the
previous bets with me using
leave due and left dom if
possible to build html structures
avoiding that these are visible
we say inside visible and
manipulated within the name and
home of the page then what
we build in a dom show if not
we want society to be so
remains hidden, for example, from poles
did s external rather than alle
manipulations by the jump street
in this case obviously wanting
keep the comedy of ours
custom item is very important
use the shadow don to avoid ad
example that the link we go to
insert is then manipulated by pity
css that we do not control then
let's create a fall
let's build inside the shell
due to this very small html with the
link is the image once this is done
then how do you complete the variables
made the http xml call is
built left the scepter tom el
internal html of it and we're done
if we try to run the page that
what happens is that in the window of the
results we would have exactly the face
corresponding to the person's avatar
of which was used as an attribute
within the delta that this
means that java positions do
tirino as soon as written can be
quietly distributed and let's say
the user the developer who decides to
include on your page will have
for free a new tag called
g profile with this detail
behavior
another implicit advantage of this
particular strategy is that of
obviously and support any
quantity of giteau file elements in
pages return to which you activate it
same identical behavior and therefore
we can easily for example
use it to make a collection of
Avatar
featured on google plus rather than
for other uses
with this finished I thank you for
attention and greet you to the next
bet
thank you so much